[Music]
fire continues to haunt this island and
the threat to its inhabitants is
spreading
[Music]
flames threaten more villages and
properties as planes and helicopters
dump water on the burning landscape
locals who've refused to leave their
homes can only watch worry and pray it
is a nervous time to live on evia
whatever you see from here it just
ruined charcoal nothing nothing left
the worst thing
is being walking up at 3 30 in the
morning
by the police telling you to evacuate
and leave everything behind
and run away something that you can't
really do
ukrainian and romanian firefighters have
flown into evia to help with the
exhausting battle against the flames
british crews are also on the ground to
help the overwhelmed greek emergency
services days without rain and high
temperatures have left this land parched
this is a very difficult situation one
of the most serious situation till now
that phase in greece
it depends minute by minute it depends
also from the
weather forecast from the winds and so
on
anyone left on the island is trying to
do what they can to help tackle the
worst fires most of them remember local
elias mastagoris is joined by his friend
john skobres who is on holiday from
canada
watching people lose their houses
watching people lose their land their
livelihood is sad every day is a cry
it's not
easy to see
you know my family's here i have four
kids
what i
take
give to him to them you know it's not
easy for me
what they need here is rain but
temperatures are predicted to remain
high in the coming days reducing
optimism the fires can be brought under
control
more international aid is coming and it
is badly needed the fires on evia have
been burning for days now displacing
thousands and destroying homes
so many left here now fear they will
have to follow the thousands who have
already fled evia crammed into boats
leaving their homes and not knowing what
would be left when they return michelle
clifford sky news evia